sind sie weiterhin für die Einhaltung
der Schuldenbremse ja oder nein für
diese Legislatur ist die Einhaltung der
Schuldenbremse also die Einhaltung das
ist ja klar die Einhaltung der
Schuldenbremse sagt das
Verfassungsgericht ist Verfassungsnorm
die muss eingehalten werden die Frage
die Stefan weil aufgeworfen hat ist ist
die Schuldenbremse klug genug
konstruiert für diese Situation also
kann man sie
stärker machen indem man sie anders
macht und das wäre meine persönliche
Meinung ja das kann man tun es gibt mir
nicht darum die Schulden oder ginge mir
nicht darum die Schuldenbremse
abzuschaffen sondern sie auszurichten
auf die Erfordernisse unserer Zeit
meiner Ansicht nach ist das eine
Stärkung aber wir haben im
Koalitionsvertrag anderes verabredet
deswegen werden wir eine Lösung für
dieses Problem nach den Regeln des
Koalitionsvertrags nur in dem Rahmen
finden den wir uns selbst jetzt gegeben
haben
und daran arbeite ich jetzt wenn ich aus
dieser Sendung
[Musik]
rausgehe